May is just about here which means a new
lineup of free PlayStation Plus games is
on the way
this month's game should make us all
feel a little less cooped up first up on
ps4 is City skylines if you've ever
wanted to build your own big city now's
your chance
the sim builder lets you construct
residential and industrial zones and
connect them with all sorts of public
transportation just make sure to find
the right economic balance you don't
want your city to fail but if it does
you can always move out to the country
with farming simulator 19 ps4 s other
free game with more than 300 real world
vehicles to work with you can explore
and tend your own farm growing crops
raising livestock and clearing forests
and yes if you don't want to get behind
the wheel of a tractor you can also ride
horses and those are your free
PlayStation Plus games for May they'll
be available from May 5th through June
1st remember that you can always check
out gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot and stay tuned as we
report on the new PS Plus lineup every
month
[Music]